[Applaudissements]
i
vers la mi juillet j'ai reçu aperçu un
matin à 6h première ronde qu'il me
manque un cheval est normalement mes
chevaux étant élevé de façon grégaire on
va dire vivre de façon quasi sauvage a
failli ce moment en toute liberté en
toute saison ils sont dehors
vivre ensemble donc mes chevaux n'ont
aucune raison de se séparer
mir-1 didier a tout de suite pensé à un
vol inquiète elle a signalé à la
gendarmerie la police à cheval a pris sa
plainte au sérieux les elle avait une
théorie beaucoup plus macabre à lui
soumettre m'a dit on a eu des cas de
chevaux qui ont été retrouvé mort égorgé
avec noah est coupée il annonce ça comme
ça mais en fait vous ne faites pas du
tout lien avec votre propre histoire là
à ce moment là vous me dites oui enfin
bon c'est ça c'est ça c'est pas possible
mais une semaine plus tard la
gendarmerie bien non c'est que sont trop
terre de 15 ans avait été retrouvé mort
son corps portant toutes les traces de
la torture il était méconnaissable il
avait de nombreuses plaies
il a vraiment subi des sévices quoi on
lui a fait mal on la fait souffrir et 7
rue haute et vous pouvez pas l'imaginer
en l'espace de quelques semaines des
histoires similaires se sont répétées
presque tous les jours partout en france
les récits sont tout aussi scabreux les
uns que les autres auraient coupé
lacération du flanc ou des parties
génitales y arracher crâne fracassé
plus de 160 signalements ont été faits à
ce jour alors moi j'étais couché j'étais
dans ma chambre
la fnac y est ouvert là je me suis mis à
la fenêtre j'ai vu deux individus dans
la mini ferme avec deux torches nicolas
des mages en a pour chasser les intrus
et s'est battu avec l'un d'entre eux qui
l'a blessé au bras
quand les deux hommes ont pris la fuite
pour de bon il a pu constater l'étendue
de la tacc intéressante du scot et la
première je pense qu'à lui être ou la
deuxième
la série c'est elle que j'ai retrouvé en
premier partait couché avec lac était un
peu lever et puis du sang partout
trois autres de ses chevaux ont aussi
été blessés le témoignage de monsieur
des maj 1 a permis de faire ce portrait
robot d'un des suspects un homme avec
des antécédents de sévices sur les
animaux a été mise en garde à vue mais
il a vite été relâchés à moi je me suis
armé oui j'ai pas c'est plus confiance à
ces gens là si la peur tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps et puis vous
avez toujours ce visage qui revient qui
revient tout le temps tout le temps du
temps j'arrive pas à me l'enlever de la
tête
on a peur que des gens se fassent
justice eux-mêmes mais que les
réversible soit commis dont claude un
peu
philippe audigier est à la tête du
groupement hippique national un syndicat
qui représente plus de 3000 centre
équestre de france
pour beaucoup de ses membres le mystère
des chevaux mutilé créé une véritable
psychose
tout comme les enquêteurs chargés de
faire la lumière sur cette déroutante
vague d' attaque
monsieur audigé crois qu'on est à la
recherche non pas d'un seul individu ou
d'un groupe mais d'une pluralité de
responsables quand vous rentrez dans un
pré la nuit
essayez d'attraper un cheval avec ou
sans lampe de poche sais pas comment ils
font mais forcément faut voir quelque
chose que vous arrivez à le faire et à
la trappe et sans la folle et sans
affoler ses copains parce que souvent
les chevaux sont les animaux grégaires
qui ont besoin de compagnie noms qui
sont rarement seul dans les airs lol est
arrivé à faire ce qu'ils font à les
attraper sans mettre la panique partout
nous on sait le faire et les techniques
pour le faire et donc forcément les gens
qui font ça sont des gens qui sont
sachant qu'ils savent le faire égorger
un cheval le regarder se vider de son
sang ça paraît inimaginable
on a des lignes de 100 viols ces
personnes là il ya un problème
pathologique livre psychopathologie
qu'on n'est plus dans un esprit
équilibré mais le problème c'est pas ça
le problème c'est que quand ces
personnes là en moins d'adrénaline donc
le concours se déplacera sur quelque
chose d'autre quels types de victimes
sera choisi qu'est ce qu'on fait après
pas on attrape un adolescent un petit
vieux qu'est ce qu'on fait voyez ça ça
m'a inquiété immédiatement je me suis
dit on est face à des esprits très
dérangé dérives sectaires acte de
mimétisme haine des équidés règlement de
comptes dans le milieu équestre ou rites
sataniques
aucune de ces hypothèses n'est écartée
par l' enquête qui prend des proportions
d' affaire d'état
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin a d'ailleurs rendu visite à
madame didier pour mobiliser l'ensemble
du pays
l'éleveuse et thérapeute soigne les
blessures profondes de la perte d'un ami
auprès des chevaux qui reste libre dans
son élevage
mais pour vraiment guérir elle a besoin
de réponses
moi je vis un deuil et effectivement il
faut aller jusqu'au bout et surtout faut
avoir une explication mon cheval n'est
pas mort de maladie n'est pas mort dans
l'accident
parce qu'il s'est fait mal lui-même
quelqu'un est venu de tuer des sas et ça
c'est grave très grave